Chris rapidfire here you like the trade
for whom I can transfer both Dan you
know the little Lakers the situation
they were in they had to make a deal
you're now operating on LeBron James
timeline and you had to come up with a
championship team to put around him the
pelicans they're backing that five six
even seven years down the line that this
Lakers team collapses no straps it's
become a lot more valuable and I was
surprised Kyle kuzmin's name was not in
those trade talks how did the Lakers
keep him out of this well by including
the swap rights in 2023 and the
protections that the pelicans have to
get better value in 2024 and 2025 I mean
I like Kyle Kuzma as well but I think if
I'm New Orleans I'd rather have the
option down the line of having that
Laker draft asset that you can use that
could potentially be even more valuable
either in terms of taking a player there
or using the trade we saw with Boston
did with Kyrie Irving using that
nebulous mess pick nobody was sure where
was gonna land it turned out what for
Boston it was number eight the nets are
the Cavaliers thought to be top three
that kind of pick and that real value
the best player that the pelicans got
was who I mean I think Ingram has the
highest upside we'll see what happens
with that number four pick Lonzo solid
and I think he'll be better outside of
the LA microscope and if he is be in
Zion have huge up-tempo potential
playing together New Orleans but Ingram
to me is still the guy that you can
build around as a top line score the
Lakers next move is what figuring out
how to fix their team and free agency
I mean business great championship teams
are built in I mean you look at the
Raptors they had their two stars in
Kauai and Kyle Lowry then they went out
or before that they went out and got
siakam with the 27th overall pick van
vliet undrafted this is where the hard
work begins
you have cornerstones in Davis and
LeBron but you've got to find your van
vliet you've got to find your your
siakam you have
space but I think a smarter move for the
Lakers might be using that cap space
amongst two or three players then make a
run at one good one Kawhi Leonard's next
home is where I felt the Clippers all
season long
and I'm gonna stick with that I mean
this who knows what's going through his
mind right now after winning a
championship but there are a couple
weeks before per agency starts and the
shadow' recruiting the Clippers have
done of him over the last year I just
think he's gonna wind up there did the
Celtics win by not trading for Anthony
Davis yes because Kyrie is gone and
that's pretty it's a pretty solid thing
to say at this point so I don't believe
you put Tatum brown and your assets in
for a guy who may leave after a year
that was way too big a risk I don't
think the the roofs gonna cave in on the
Celtics here Dan they've still got a
very good team and they've got a team
that is gonna have flexibility to make a
deal over the next few months it's not a
few weeks but I think they made the
right move not going all-in on ante
Davis Kevin Durant is where next year
I'm gonna say New York and not playing
at all next season of these teams who do
you think finishes with a better record
than the Lakers this upcoming season
Portland Houston Golden State
Denver Houston and Denver for sure
Portland maybe again chemistry matters
with teams and whatever the Lakers do
it's gonna take them some time to come
together I don't see them being a oh
seven oh eight Celtics team that comes
together and rattles off whatever was 25
wins in their first 30 games I think
they might be better than the team you
mention at the end of the season but
regular season big win for the Rockets
here by the way Dan with everything
that's happened in the NBA in the last
couple of weeks the Rockets have
chemistry they've got a group that knows
they could win against a lot of teams in
the playoffs that team in Houston I
think if Kauai leaves they're gonna be
at least the Co favored to win next year
thank you Chris we appreciate your time
as always
ident that's Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior NBA
writer for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]